اولا اود ان اعبر عن شكري وامتنان الكبير
للجنود وضباط في الخطوط الاماميه في
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه كلهم ينفذون
مهامهم بشكل ناجح ويخاطرون بانفسهم
وكذلك
يدافعون عن زملائهم في حرب كذلك علينا
اليوم ان نتذكر من سقط في خلال هذه
العمليه بدقيقه صمت
شكرا جزيلا
لوزاره الدفاع من الواضح ان اليوم روسيا
تستخدم قدراتها العسكريه
وعمليا
تحارب جميع دول الناتو على اي حال
يدافعون عن روسيا بشكل
اهداف التي ستنفذ في نهايه المطاف
في نهايه المطاف كذلك سوف يتم تعزيز وتامر
الحياه سليمه الهانئه لكل مواطني روسيا ان
همم
كل انواع القوات العسكريه تزداد بشكل
مزيد من هذه العمليه بشكل مت واود ان اشكر
كل همم من هم في مواقع القتال وينفذون همم
خدمه العلم بما في ذلك همم الجنود في
وحدات الدبابات
وكذلك القوات المشاهده
وكذلك
الحرس
الوطني وغيرها من انواع قوات العسكريه
الذين
يكافحونه
[موسيقى]
كما حارب اجدادنا في الحرب الوطنيه العظمى
وكذلك الشكر همم عاملين في مجال الصحه
والاطباء والممرضين الذين يقدمون المساعده
وكذلك همم مدنيين الذين يقومون
كل ما يلزم من بنى تحتيه وغيرها لتنفيذ
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ومع ذلك فان
اعمال القتاليه قد وضعت مسائل
علينا كما يقال ان همم نعمل عليها بشكل
جاد واا
اقصد هنا
الاتصال بين الوحدات والقوات
الحربيه وتحديد الاهداف وتلك التجربه
القتاليه التي علينا وسوف نقوم باستخدامها
في في مستقبل تطوير القوات المسلحه
الروسيه اليوم مهمتنا هي تنفيذ
الاجراءات
لتطوير والتحديث همم
للقوات بشكل شامل وممل
التي تستخدم خلال العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
جيدا وكل ذلك
همم
لابد من تحليلها بشكل دقيق
وعميق لاستخدامها في تطوير قواتنا
العسكريه ورفع المهاره القتاليه لجيوشنا
وكذلك همم هيئات الامنيه الاخرى
بارون
التنفيذ العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو كما
قلت تحليل كل هذه المعلومات
وتحضير كل ما يلزم للقوات العامله في
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وان الخبره التي اتخذها وحصل عليها
مقاتلونا خلال همم مشاركه في المعارك في
سوريا لابد من الاستفاده منها اليوم بما
في ذلك من خلال اجراء التدريبات على همم
كافه مستويات بما في ذلك تجهيز وتدريب
الضباط والجنود
ان يكون لدينا كوادر اضافيه همم مدربه
ثانيه
اداره وزاره الدفاع على انه لابد من
التعامل والتنسيق بشكل وثيق همم ضمن
الهيئات التي تم
انشائها لمجلس التنسيق وقبل كل شيء مع
رؤساء الاقاليم وكذلك مع المجمع العسكري
التقني ولابد من
الاستمرار
بتقديم
معرفه
على الخطوط الاوليه وانا اشكرهم على ذلك
لانهم همم يقومون ب همم ضمن الاعمال
العسكريه الحقيقيه بالتاكد والتحقق من
تكتكات الحربيه وتحديثها وتطويرها وبشكل
عام لابد من همم
المتعلقه بالوزاره ونحن نرى كيف يعملون
بشكل
مهندسين والعلماء سوف نقوم بتحديث نستمر
همم
تقنيه
كذلك لابد من التنسيق بين
الهيئات التقنيه والعلميه ووزاره الدفاع
وقبل كل شيء
لتعزيز المعدات والملزمات والذخائر للقوات
ثالثا
سنستمر
للقوات النوويه وهذه وهذا ضمان لسيادتها
ووحده ارادنا
بشكل
[موسيقى]
توازن النووي في العالم
91% الاولى
ليس لها مثيل همم في العالم ففي بدايه همم
يناير من العامل همم
سوف همم
فرقاطه
بالخدمه
والتي تزود بمنظومه
المطلقه من البحر
سوف نزود القوات الاستراتيجيه بكل انواع
الاسلحه الحديثه وكل الخطط اكرر مره ثانيه
يجب تنفيذها وستنفذ اضافه لذلك لابد من
تزويد قدرات القوات الفضل الجويه الفضائيه
وخاصه همم
خلال عملهم في مناطق التي تتواجد فيها
احدث المنظمات الدفاعيه الجويه وكذلك لابد
من تحديث همم
الاليات الهجوميه واستخدامها
اضافه الى ذلك ان استخدام السيارات اصبح
امرا همم
واقعه لذلك لابد من
عمل على هذا الموضوع
وبالتالي فان الهدف همم يتم
القضاء عليه بسرعه والمعلومات تعالج بشكل
سريع وبالتالي لا بد من همم
تكامل عمل المسيارات ضمن همم هيئات
الاستخباراتيه العسكريه همم
وهذا لابد من تنفيذه في الوقت القريب
العاجل واقصد اليوم قبل غدا همم وبالتالي
همم لابد من تزويد همم المجندين بكل هذه
الخبرات بالاضافه الى المعدات
اللازمه له من التركيز وا ان وزاره الدفاع
تعمل على ذلك ولكن على ايه حال او ان همم
اقول بانه لابد من تزويد المجندين بكل ما
يلزم من معدات صحيه واطعمه والبسه دافئه
واسلحه لابد من تزويدهم ايضا باجهزه
الاستطلاع الليليه ومن احدث همم
اصف همم واذكر كل شيء ولكن اقول انه يجب
ان يكون لدى كل جندي ما هو همم
[موسيقى]
لان فاذا كانت الاجراءات لهذا التزويد قد
اصبحت قديمه لابد من تحديثها بشكل همم
سريع وكل المسؤولين في وزاره الدفاع هي
همم هم موجودون اليوم هنا وليس لدينا اي
مشكله في التمويل همم دوله همم تعطي كل ما
يطلبه الجيش
اتمنى بان يكون الرد همم
واضح من قبل وزاره الدفاع وان نصل الى
النتيجه المطلوبه
ولدينا اكرر مره اخرى اه خبره باستخدام
المسيارات
المائيه
لذلك لابد من
انتاج
المسيرات سواء الجويه او البحريه ب همم
احدث همم
الصفات والمواصفات القتاليه بما في ذلك
همم
الذكاء الصناعي ولا بد من تحديث
الهجوميه اضافه لابد من تحديث همم
العمل الاكثر فعاله لذلك لابد من استخدام
الذكاء الصناعي في كل المراحل اتخاذ
القرار همم
اظهرها
فان ال ااه احدث الاسلحه واكثرها النجاحه
هي الاسلحه التي تعمل بشكل ذاتي اضافه الى
ذلك همم
التعبئه الجزئيه التي جرت قد اظهرت الكثير
من المشاكل همم
وانا اعلم بان الاجراءات المطلوبه تتخذ
وتنفذ الان ولكن لابد من تحديث هذه
المنظومه بما في ذلك همم
منظومه التفويض العسكري بما في ذلك همم
رقمه همم قاعده البيانات
كذلك همم اتصال بين ال همم مراكز
العسكريه الاقليميه وكذلك المجمع العسكري
التقني اضافه الى ذلك
اريد برجوله
الف شخص قد
تم تعبئهم
وكما تحدث وزير الدفاع
وهمم قاد في وزاره الدفاع ان 1500 موجودون
اليوم في ميادين التدريب وهذا كافن همم
احتياطين كافه لتنفيذ العمليه العسكريه
الناس اليوم همم المجنونه في ضمن هذه
التعب ياخذون التدريب المناسب
والمواطنون يساعدون الجنود حيث يقومون
بتزويده همم
السيارات
والاشياء والالبسه الدافئه اضافه الى
الرسائل التي همم تقوي من معناويات الجنود
مع ذلك همم وزاره الدفاع تقوم بكل ذلك
ولكن يجب ان نشكر المواطنين على همم هذه
المبادرات
اضافه الى ذلك لابد من الاخذ بعين
الاعتبار
الانتقادات التي نسمعها همم من الواضح ان
الناس الذين يرون المشاكل وهذه المشاكل
موجوده انه ردود الفعل يمكن ان تكون همم
مليئه بالمشاعر اكثر ولكن همم
هم يشرون
لا يجب علينا ان نصمت عن هذه المشاكل
علينا ان نحلها جدا همم
الجيش والشعب كان دائما قوتنا همم وهذا
شيء سيكون همم كذلك اليوم واعطي الكلمه
لوزير الدفاع همم سرقه
الرفق والقائد العام الاعلى ابدا في تقرير
من العمليه العسكريه الخاصه اليوم يواجهه
العسكريون الروس القوات المسلحه الموحد
الغربيه فان الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
تضخ الاسلحه
وتدربوا المسلحين الاوكرانيين ويوجهون الى
هناك المدربين والخبراء
ويشنون حربا اعلاميه ضدنا ويستخدمون
اساليب شات بما في ذلك الاعمال الارهابيه
وقصف المناطق السكنيه باستخدام الاسلحه
الثقيله في الدول الغربيه لا تلاحظ كل هذه
الجرائم مثل خطوات وعناصر الابتزاز النووي
في ذلك الهجوم والقصف
على محطه الزباروجي النوويه وبما في ذلك
التهديدات باستخدام ما يسمى بالقنبله
النوويه القذره كل هذه الاجراءات تتاخذه
من قبل الولايات المتحده
لتعزيز ستراتها وهيمنتها وما يسيروا القلق
الكبير هو زياده التواجد العسكري
الاطلسي بالقرب من حدود الاتحاد الروسي
وجمهوريه بيلاروس وايضا سعي الغرب الى
اطاله امد
الاعمال القتاليه في اوكرانيا لاضعاف
روسيا
فان الاهداف
الحقيقيه
لاتفاقيات منسك بعد همم بدات واضحه بعد
تصريحات الرئيس الاوكراني السابق
باراشينكا والمستشاره انجيل ميركل وبعد
عام 2014 وصلت الى زمام السلطه قوه معاديه
لروسيا وهي قامت بالفصل بين الشعب الشعب
بين الشعبين الشقيقين ما ادى الى الاعمال
اللي قتاليه في دون بس الا ان روسيا دائما
كانت همم تقف الى وتدعوا الى اجراء
مفاوضات حول التسويه السلميه وفي الظروف
الحاليه تقوم والقوات المسلحه الروسيه
بمواصله الاعمال القتاليه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه وقدراتها القتاليه
وتتاخذ
فدابير الشات عليه الحلقه الاولى دون سقوط
الخسائر بين المدنيين الاوكرانيين
وفي نتيجه الاعمال القتاليه قد تكبدت
القوات الاوكرانيه همم خسائر فادحه بين
الارواح والمعدات العسكريه
والازياده القدرات القتاليه زادت القوات
الاطلسيه التزويده اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
حيث انفقوا 97 مليار دولار وهذا بمرتين
اكبر اكثر من المعدات والاسلحه التي تركت
في افغانستان بعد انسحاب الولايات المتحده
كامله
الكويت
قمر اصطناعي تستخدم
لمراقبه الاعمال القتاليه وايضا هناك
اخصائيون عسكريون يستخدمون لمواصله مكافحه
همم روسيا في المجال الاعلامي
ونفهمه تماما
نادر
المئات من القنوات التلفزيونيه ووسائل
الاعلام وفي شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
من قبل الوسائل الاعلام الغربيه حول
الجرائم التي ترتكبها القوات الاوكرانيه
وفي نفس الوقت يتم تم تم جيده همم
المجرمين من النظام
الجدد ويصفون اعمالهم بانها اجراءات
الدفاع النفسي
على المعلومات حول اعدام همم جنود
الاوكرانيين الذين لا ينتثلون لتنفيذ
اوامر القاده المسلحين الاوكرانيين
للمشاركه في الاعمال القتاليه
مش هاشتغل كنترول ماشي كويس في السير
العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه قمنا بزياده همم عدد
قواتنا في منطقه الاعمال القتاليه واجرين
عمليه التعبئه الجزئيه واصبحت امتحان جادا
واهم بالنسبه لمنظومه التعبئه والتدريب
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه
كنا نواجهه المشاكل المتعلقه باستدعاء
العسكريين من الاحتياط وكل هذه الصعوبات
والمشاكل
كنا نقوم بمعالجتها خلال تنفيذ عمليه
تعبئه الجزئيه وكنا نتخذ اجراءات عاجله
لاستكمال عمليه
الامداد والتموين وفي نهايه المطاف تم
تنفيذ كافه الاجراءات لتعبئه الجزئيه حيث
تم استدعاء 300,000 عسكري من الاحتياط
ولعب دورا كبيرا في ذلك العمل المتكامل
والمنسق لجميع الهيئات الحكوميه والسلطه
المركزيه
والاقليميه بشكل خاص اريد ان اشيد بالموقف
الوطني
20,000 متطوع همم ذهبوا الى مراكز التعبئه
للالتحاق بالخدمه في صفوف القوات المسلحه
في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
التي تم اتخاذها من قبل رئيس الدوله فان
العسكريين الذين تم استدعائهم من الاحتياط
يحصلون على نفس الروايه والمرطبات التي
يحصل عليها
العسكريون
متعاقدون
الكبير
التي تشتغل وتعتني
العمل التوجيه المعنوي
والتدريب الافراد
القتاليه في نهايه المطاف قد تمكنا من رفع
القدرات القتاليه لقواتنا وتنشيط الاعمال
القتاليه وقد تم التحرير خمسه اضعاف من
الاراضي التي كانت همم تحت سيطره
جمهوريتين دونيتك ولوكا قبل 28
فبراير تم تحرير مدينه ماريوبا التي حولت
نظام كيف الى حسن قوي ومعزز
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه
تم القضاء على اكثر من اربعه الاف
مسلح اوكراني
وبدات هناك اجراءات
لاستعاده الحياه السلميه الى ميناء
مريوبال وميناء بيردانسك نقوم
همم ايصال السفن الى هناك
لاستعاده الحياه السلميه
وبحر الزوج تحول الى بحر داخلي لروسيا كما
قال كان ذلك على مداره ثلاثه قرون
الدرجه نيتروجينيه
المرور عبر السكك الحديد مع دون باس حيث
يتم نقل الشحنات الى مريول وبردانسك
وغيرها من البلدات والمدن المحرره بعد بسط
سيطره على قناه القرم الشمالي ااا استطعنا
استعاده امداد شبه جزيره القرم بالمياه
العذبه
لستات كيف
وان العسكريين
الروس
يظهرون
نشاطاتهم
ويحققون ماثر قتاليه حقيقيه لقد اكتسب ااا
اكثر من 250 عسكري متعاقد همم خبره قتاليه
في منطقه الاعمال العسكريه
بازاله الالغام من الاراضي المحرره
ويجري عدد بناء للمباني السكنيه في مدينه
ماريوبالا وغيرها من البلدات
حيث تم بناء مركزين طبيين متكاملين مزودين
باحدث الاجهزه
الطبيه وهناك عمل كبير يجري لاستعاده ااه
تزويد جمهوريه دينيسكو بالمياه حيث تم
بناءه قنوات المياه
الجديده طولها
194 كلم ما سوف يؤمن التزويد مدينه دنيسك
بالمياه ايضا بشكل عام فان العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه ازهرت المهاره العاليه
للقيادات والاركان والجاهزيه العسكريين
الروس لتنفيذ اصعب المهمات فان الاسلحه
والمعدات القتاليه الروسيه اثبتت جدارتها
ومتنتها وهذه العمليه تعطي فرصه نادره
لتحليل الاساليب الحديثه لاخوض الاعمال
القتاليه بمشاركه انواع وافرع القوات
المختلفه
وسوف يتم استخلاص هذه العبر في الخطه
المستقبليه
لتدريب والتجهيز القوات اما قياده الدوله
والشعب
الروسي فاثبتت وحده الجيش والمجتمع في هذه
السنه وزاره الدفاع همم تقوم بحل وتنفيذ
قضايا مهمه اخرى في بدايه العمل جاري
بمشاركه الدول الاعضاء في منظمه الامن
الجماعي ااه
قمنا باحباط محاوله تنفيذ الثوره الملونه
في كازاخستان وايضا قواتنا تحافظ على
السلام في سوريا
وان نقوم بازاله الالغام في المناطق
السكنيه ونقدم المساعدات الطبيه للمواطنين
في تلك البلدان والمناطق اما الثالوث
النووي الروسيف
يمتلك قدره وجاهزيه عاليه
وذلك بفضل همم
تزويدي هذه القوات بالاسلحه الجديده وهذه
النسبه التصل الى 91% حيث تم اعاده تصليح
لثلاثه افواج للصواريخ الاستراتيجيه
بالصواريخ من طراز يارس وهناك ايضا اخر
للصواريخ الاستراتيجيه بدا في الخدمه
وباستخدام الصواريخ افاكارد العابره
للقارات
وهناك ايضا فوج اخر همم تم تزويده
بالصاروخ عبر القارات الاستراتيجي صارمات
وايضا
دخلت الخدمه العسكريه في هذه القوات اا
طائره قادفات استراتيجيه تو ااه
تم اجراء
مناورات مشتركه بما في ذلك مع القوات
المسلحه لجمهوريه سن الشعبيه
القوات البحريه
جديده
وايضا تزداد الامكانيات القتاليه لانواع
وافرع القوات المسلحه على القوات الجويه
الفضائيه
حصلت على منظومه
مشتركه
للاتصالات وتم اطلاق
القمر الاصطناعي الجديد الذي يمكننه من
السيطره على المناطق التاسعه في
الجزء الشمالي للبلاد
ايضا ازدادت عدد الطائرات
التدريبيه في هذه السنه تم تخريج الدفعه
الاولى من الطيارين من النساء القوات
البحريه حصلت على احدث السفن والزوارق
البحريه
بدات تزويد القوات
بالصواريخ
وفي الوقت الحالي يجري تزويد الفرقات
الاميرات
الصواريخ الفرد الصوتيه ومن اهم مهمات
لتنفيذ الحجوزات الحكوميه في عام 2020
كانت تزويد القوات المسلحه
بالمعدات خاصه
وكذلك من خلال التزويدها باحدث المجموعات
المتنقله للاسلحه
تجربه
تنفيذي كل الخطط من قبل اللجنه المشتركه
التي تشمل الممثلين عن وزاره الدفاع
وصناعه الدفاعيه المعنيه وفي عام 2022
فان الموارد الماليه وباعتبار الاسلحه
والمعدات الجديده التي تم ان همم ادخالها
في الخدمه
فزاد حجم هذه المخصصات ب 30%
دوستادي بيوتينج
69 الى اكثر من 100%
وبشكل عام تم تنفيذ كل الحجوزات الحكوميه
بنسبه 91% وكل همم اجراءات المتعلقه
بالتدريب العمليات
والاستراتيجي تم تنفيذها في السنه الجاريه
وفي بدايه العام المجاري همم تم اجراء
مناورات بحريه واسعه النطاق وتم تنفيذه
خلالها المهام الخاصه بالرد على التهديدات
العسكريه همم روسيا من الاتجاهات البحريه
وان كانت مناورات الشارقه همم
شامله الممثلين عن 14 دوله اجنبيه ومن
خصائص تلك المناورات اصبحت تشكيل المجموعه
ولي للقوات لحل القضايا المشتركه
وهذه المناورات اظهرت القدره على تنفيذ
المهام القتاليه وبجداره
لضمان الامن الاقليميه اما القوات
الصاروخيه
الاستراتيجيه خلال مناوراتها نفذت المهمه
الخاصه بالردعه لاستخدام العضو الافتراضي
للاسلحه النوويه في منطقه القطبيه في شبه
جزيره شيكودكا همم جاره البعثه العلميه
وتم البحث عن همم مختلف في ال- همم الظروف
واساليب استخدام للاسلحه الحديثه في
المناطق القطبيه وبغد النظر عن محاولات
الغرب لعزل روسيا نستمر في توسيع
الجغرافيا للتعاون العسكري والتقني حيث
تقوم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في تطوير
علاقتها مع اكثر من مئه م م من من 109 دول
في افريقيا واسيا وامريكا اللاتينيه
واجرينا عاشرات من الاجراءات الهامه
المشتركه بمشاركه الممثلين عن الدول
العالم
اكثر من خمسه الاف
و300 عسكري من 34 دوله
الثمانيه اعوام اللي همم
خوض همم العاب همم العسكريه تم اعاده بناء
وتطوير القاعده الماديه التي تستخدم
لاجراء مثل هذه المناورات
وايضا هناك همم فعاليات اخرى مرتبطه
بالمنتدى الدولي للامن الجيش
وحضر هذا المنتدى في الاعوام الماضيه اكثر
من همم
تم عقد الصفقات في هذه السنه تقدر
باكثر من 25 مليار
وهذا المنتدى يعتبر همم
معرضا مرموقا دوليا وفي اغسطس العام
الجاري ان عقد مؤتمر الامن شارك فيه همم
الممثلون عن سبعين دوله وعددهم 700 شخص
وفي السنه الجاريه ايضا ان عقد المؤتمر
المعادي
للفاشيه وشرك فيه
المحاربون القدامى والممثلون عن الدول
الاجنبيه والملحقون العسكريون اللي همم 26
الدوله فان اعضاء المؤتمر همم
استنكروا جميع المظاهر
التمييز العنصر
والفاشيه ويتفقنا على عقد هذا المؤتمر
سنويا فان المدرسه العسكريه العليا
الروسيه تعتبر من افضل المدارس العسكريه
في العالم
ويتعلموا في مؤسساتنا التعليميه العسكريه
همم لها من العسكريين الاجانب
ابتداء من شهر سبتمبر دخل في هذه المؤسسه
ايضا المعهد
العسكري اللي ايه مدينه الدونيس في
سبتمبر العمل مقبل سوف نقوم بفتح مدرسه
همم
ثانويه عسكريه في مدينه اركوس
هناك ايضا
هيئه وطنيه تعتني بالتعامل مع المحاربين
القدامى
اشكركم السيد الرئيس على دعم هذه المبادره